cindy jackson mesdames messieurs alors
si ni jackson c'est votre vrai nom mais
vous n'êtes plus connu sous le nom de
michael jackson
barbie acquis depuis 1988 chine dit vous
vous efforcez de ressembler 47
opérations de chirurgie esthétique et
vous avez osé faire ce que personne
n'avait osé faire avant vous c'est à
dire une modification intégrale du
visage et du corps y compris au niveau
de la structure osseuse mais oui voilà
entre la cindy du départ et la barbie
d'aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun
rapport si c'était pour ressembler à
barbie ou pour être plus belle que vous
pensez être
pour être plus belle main
parce qu'en fait on me taquinait
toujours lorsque j'étais à petit à cause
de mon menton et cetera je ne venais pas
du bon endroit dans la ville mes parents
étaient pauvres j'ai pris en fait je
rêvais d'une vie plus glamour
c'est important uniquement pour être
pour avoir une autre vie ce n'était
peut-être plus facile de ressemble à un
télé tu dis non
j'ai pensé vous donneriez un enfant qui
veut se transformer en train électrique
et vous où leurs données qu'elles
contiennent moi rester naturel moi
j'aime beaucoup la fille de gauche vous
n'échapperez pas cindy de toute façon un
interview barbet
[Musique]
alors
comment vous faites comment vous faites
pour vous habiller le matin est ce qu'à
une petite fille qui vient à vous
habiller le matin
jusqu'à une petite fille qui vient vous
habiller le matin comme vous et
maintenant vous êtes une poupée barbie
quelle petite fille s'annonce d'ailleurs
si vous voulez dire ouais quand demandé
c'est vous
et des triplés with you est ce qu'on
peut lui expliquer que c'était un jeu en
jouant à l'interview barbie et qu'après
on parlera sérieusement
ok tu as tout en fait
maintenant je comprends le sentiment
français
alors comment vous faites pour vous
habiller le matin jusqu'à une petite
fille qui vient vous habiller
non c'est ma mère qui le sait tout comme
votre maison maintenant comme on peut le
voir si je vous coupe les cheveux est ce
qu'il ya un bouton ou je peux appuyer
pour que ça repousse
ça dépend du bouton sur lequel vous
appuyez rien compris
est ce qu'il ya des toilettes chez vous
non il est partagé par mais paris comme
à un copain qu'elle ne soit pas qu'il a
un peu con quand même non
1 mais bon c'est à cause des accessoires
que les hommes
[Musique]
gc
m
bien alors cindy vous êtes né en 1955
dans une petite ville de deux fermiers
de l'audio et vous avez une enfance dans
une communauté assez souvent au milieu
des champs de maïs et vous rêviez étant
enfants d'une vie plus plus glamour à 6
ans vos parents vous offre une poupée
barbie qui devient le support de vos
fantasmes c'est comme ça que ça a
commencé
en fait c'est un peu comme un talisman
pour moi c'était le symbole d'une autre
vie pour moi et je me disais qu'il
devait bien y avoir une autre vie plus
loin que les champs de maïs et
moi je ne voyais que la vie des paysans
des ouvriers
je travaillais dans une zone y voilà moi
je ne savais pas très bien où aller
c'était à la fin des années 50 et en
1959 j'ai ma première poupée barbie est
pour moi elle représentait tout
simplement quelque chose de totalement
différent
et à cette époque barbie ne portait pas
tous ses habits très très brillant rose
en fait elle portait des habits de mode
avait beaucoup de place et maintenant la
barbie c'est quelque chose de totalement
différent
la barbie moderne n'est pas du tout ce
que j'avais à l'esprit à l'époque alors
à l'époque voulez vous évader de cette
petite ville un petit peu étouffante et
puis aussi vous évader de votre corps
parce que vous aimez pas votre corps
quand vous êtes enfant vous semblez
plutôt à votre père avec les traits un
peu un peu un peu rude qu'à votre mère
en fait cela ne me dérangeait pas de
ressembler à man bancaire mais j'avais
vraiment un instinct masculin tandis que
ma soeur ressemble à ma mère est en fait
il l'a traitée de manière tellement
différente de moi on me traitait comme
quelqu'un d'inférieur hamas heures en
fait c'était toujours ma soeur qui
réussissaient tout aussi je faisais une
erreur elle aussi et bien si - condé est
en fait elle avait vraiment une vie
différente à cause de son apparence
physique et je savais que ça ne
concernait pas que ma soeur je savais
que toutes les filles mignonnes et est
vraiment différente
deux mois
alors comme une personne ne
s'intéressait à moi j'étais invisible
n'existiez pas c'est vrai et en 77 vous
quitter les états unis pour londres où
vivait toujours au début vous faites
delà de la musique et en
1988 à la mort de votre père vous
recevez un héritage et vous commencez
les opération chirurgicale destinée à
vous faire ressembler disons à la à la
poupée barbie
je n'avais jamais pensé à la chirurgie
esthétique avant d'avoir de l'argent
parce que j'ai toujours dû travailler
beaucoup pour avoir de l'argent et
jamais je n'aurais pensé que j'aurais pu
réaliser mon rêve mais le au moment où
j'ai réalisé que j'avais d'argent bien
je n'ai pas hésité et je n'avais pas
peur de travailler très dur j'étais
ambitieuse
je n'étais pas stupides j'avais de très
bonnes notes à l'école mais ce qui me
manquait c'était l'apparence physique
donc immédiatement je me suis dit je
n'ai pas très envie de voyager d'acheter
une grande maison d'avoir des déshabille
très bon en fait je voulais vraiment
être belle
je je me demande
si vous avez un enfant si vous en avez
et ne vont pas vous ressemblez
je suis trop âgé pour avoir des enfants
maintenant donc ça ne me posera pas mais
j'ai pensé au départ je me suis dit
c'est bien moi de toute façon je
ressemble et permanent non plus donc bon
il pourrait sembler alors points mais je
n'aurais pas ses enfants elle peut le
faire opérer pour qu'ils ressemblent à
que nous abordons dans 20 ou 30 ans
comment vous envisager l'avenir
et bien jor-el la même inférences
physique maintenant c'est tout l'espace
entre nous
vous avez remarqué aussi tu sais que
cindy si nous finissions qu'amatrice ont
évoqué sans moi
pas mal eh oui pourtant pour certains
c'est noël ce soir dites-moi cindy c'est
vrai que j'avais eu une aventure avec
james hewitt l'amant de lady di
est-ce que conquérant l'extérieur on
change l'intérieur
c'est bien ce qui se produit c'est qu'en
fait ça change les autres et de
personnes parce que les autres personnes
nous regardent différemment
peut-être un même personne un intérieur
je vous sentez de la même manière et
vous agissez de la même manière mais les
autres personnes de traite de manière
totalement différente et nous faisons
tout cela en fait il est lié un
millionnaire qui était très mal habillés
à ce moment-là à bien vous et moi nous
diriez que qui ne vaut rien par contre
quelqu'un de très beaux et bien et bien
si cela change tout on regarde les
personnes et puis on se fait une
certaine idée on a des hypothèses sur
ses personnels ces personnes là et bien
leur apparence physique leur tenue
vestimentaire
portées contre
elle par edel est pas connu de tous est
ce que voudrait que dans l'avenir tout
le monde se fera opérer
eh bien non c'est quelque chose qui se
fait de plus en plus si nokia quand même
c'est trop long
on regarde ça fait quand même regarde
jamais il faudrait qu'il arrête de
mentir c'est tout bon apparemment de ce
qu'on a
besoin de laurent un incroyable je joue
à la poupée de
600 bénévoles
vous pensez quoi cindy ou pensez quoi de
chair
et bien je les admire beaucoup
elle est très belle mais moi je la
trouve très sympa qu'en pensez vous moi
je les ai connus quand j'avais 18 ans
elle était déjà la très jolie maintenant
j'ai beaucoup plus elle est toujours la
très jolie dont je considère que c'est
un bel exploit vous pensez quoi de
michael jackson
je les ai rencontrés et
vous savez il n'a pas eu une enfance
très heureuse et je crois qu'ils se
sentir très différents tout le monde et
peut-être que c'est quelque chose qui
veut exprimer par son apparence en fait
ce sont probablement très bizarre à
l'intérieur de mazinho ils sont sympas
les pokémon
les catcheurs et comment dans la vie
voilà c'était cindy jackson alias barbie
merci d'avoir été avec nous cinq vols
sont commis je vous demande tous tes
hollande tous fait
bush en
2004 moment toutes
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux